Let's do one more example of where we would use a confidence interval before we
move on. Well, hopefully you're enjoying the class so far. How would we measure
this? Maybe one way is to look at the number of minutes that each person has
watched of the videos. Divided by the total minutes that are available we could
call this something like the engagement ratio because this provides some
indication of how engaged you are. If you're watching more video then you are
probably more engaged. As of March 11th, when I'm recording this, there are
8,702 students enrolled in the course. I made up this hypothetical data set the
link is below, unfortunately I couldn't get the actual data for every student,
but I think the shape is pretty close to what it really is. And that's just the
nature of the mook. A lot of people sign up because it's free and easy, but they
don't progress through the course or they just sign up with the intention of
doing it later. However if you're taking the course for credit, which I think
about a hundred of you are, you're probably up here on the distribution, making
your way through the course to get credit for it. So first of all, calculate the
mean and standard deviation for this data. This is a pretty big data set, so try
to make use of the keyboard shortcuts that you've learned before. Treat this as
a population and round to the nearest thousandths or three decimal places.